boa noite
tudo bem prazer obrigado pelo convite
bom é pra começar aqui com vocês
gostaria de fazer uma pergunta um
pouquinho provocativo uma vez que o
título por si só ele é provocativo
quando percebi que não seria 1% e
prudentemente então nesse caso eu
pergunto quem é que acha que o
conhecimento é e limitado levanta a mão
favor ilimitado uma galera que há um
pessoal como relutante aí né pois é bom
é muito interessante quando a gente pára
para refletir sobre essa questão que
envolve o conhecimento uma vez que
quando a gente escolhe algo ou a gente
seleciona o objeto de estudo esse objeto
de estudo invariavelmente está
relacionado com a nossa própria
trajetória de vida e isso não é uma
atitude egoísta porque na verdade nós
nos interessamos por algo e esse alguém
vai acompanhando nossa trajetória e
automaticamente a nossa própria
existência
então no meu caso a minha graduação é
toda a história mestrado em história e
doutorado em história e fazendo recorte
o percebendo que eu gosto de fazer que
na verdade em investigar juventude
investigar rock estudar nova república
isso tem uma ligação muito forte com a
minha época de jovem claro eu nasci em
santo andré na grande são paulo
mas a maior parte da minha vida passei
no interior de são paulo o município
chamado paraguaçu paulista
aproximadamente r 45 mil habitantes não
é lá grande coisa mas em contrapartida
foi lá que eu tive as minhas
experiências mais interessantes enquanto
jovem
confesso que de modo geral a minha
experiência quando joga foi muito
sandy andávamos um grupo grande aquela
rota aquele monte de meninos e caroto
sofro indo às vezes do lazer da direcção
daquela coisa toda não era o indivíduo
mais endinheirado do meu grupo os não
acredito que é um dos mais celebrados
não usava roupas de marca
a record também que não chamava tanta
atenção das garotas se comparado os meus
demais amigos uma vez que eles são bem
mais bonito que eu e também não andava
com o carro da moda
tanto é que o casal que andava enquanto
os meus amigos ele estava a andar com o
carro zero com rodas de liga de montada
roda com sei lá só eu estava andando aí
com 11 86
já a álcool só que o veneno pois bem mas
tirando essas qualidades que eu acredito
que eu realmente não tinha tenho duas em
específico que eu acho que serve como
peso eu nunca me sentir mais inteligente
que os meus amigos nunca por sinal
reconhece a nobreza e fala com toda
certeza que eu convivi com pessoas que
elas tenham capacidade intelectual muito
maior que a mim e é lindo conviver com
esse tipo de gente
na verdade esse tipo de pessoa você tem
que extrair o máximo porque você não
sabe se vai aparecer de novo ao longo da
sua existência mas do outro lado e aí
lógico eu vou puxar um pouco a sardinha
para o meu lado eu entendo que eu era um
sujeito que tinha uma constante busca de
tentar entender o mundo ao redor então
às vezes eu apitava muito mais em
escutar o que falar
pode parecer hoje o inverso mas na minha
juventude era assim então eu gostava de
tentar perceber as relações sociais
eu gosto muito de reparar no
comportamento nas formas como vocês
estão eu sou apaixonar príncipe coisa e
é claro que invariavelmente esse tipo de
circunstância
ele montou influenciou a minha concepção
de mundo
pois bem ao passo que eu crescia como
jovem eu entrei no curso de graduação
história eu lembro com muita saudade
falava nossa brincando com os meus
amigos de graduação
eu pensava mais ou menos assim
sei lá se eu continuasse estudando
fazendo mestrado doutorado
se eu chegasse a ser um por cento do que
o limite foi ótimo
mitchell filósofo alemão do século 19
uma das mentes mais brilhantes da
humanidade e eu na minha um gênio a
juventude acreditava que um dia poderia
chegar um por cento que lhe foi pois bem
foi passando o tempo e emprego mestrado
foi passando o doutorado e
gradativamente eu fui assimilando
perspectivas e influência para lá
se você pega meu livro tem o nome citado
na minha tese de doutorado ou se tem um
limite quer dizer eu sou apaixonado pelo
carro funcionou porque eu acho
fascinante gente que provoca e unity ele
é provocativo
então a forma como a questão nas
instituições
a forma como ele coloca ideologias
políticas o conceito de dirigismo fim
mente pra mim uma das grandes mentes do
acidente e é claro que eu tenho essa
perspectiva em torno do autor
e aí eu sempre pensava 1% da quem sabe o
que acontece
o que acontece quando é eu acho
importante a gente pegar e fazer um
balanço fazer um contrapeso com relação
à há como a gente lida na verdade com a
população de mestres e doutores desse
país
tirando os problemas estruturais que eu
não vou encher vocês nós temos mais é a
uma outra perspectiva que eu acho muito
importante que seria a seguinte
quem escolhe fazer mestrado doutorado
criou se um mito no brasil de quem faz
mestrado doutorado em engenharia
eu fico me perguntando aonde 'tá'
genialidade nisso por um outro lado
porque eu sempre gosto de pensar no peso
da bola colocar o peso na balança
eu fico me perguntando essas pessoas que
acham que acreditam que fazer mestrado e
doutorado é coisa fácil tá falando sério
[Música]
como tudo no brasil fato um debate
equilíbrio a gente considera hora o
indivíduo que faz mestrado doutorado ser
genial que eu acho que esse time tem que
ser extirpado e num segundo momento você
considera que um cara que faz doutorado
não fez nada
é sinal claro de um país que reflete
muito pouco sobre a condição de pós
graduandos mestrandos doutorandos enfim
pois bem feita e esse pré balanço aí
você poderia a gente poderia pensar por
outro lado se você acha que eu fosse na
pacha equiparável mente tipo ah tá
chorando as pitangas à toa
me permita me dar um exemplo muito
simples imagina você você acorda no
domingo com uma ideia fixa na sua mente
essa idéia que incomoda
só que você como você é dotar de livre
arbítrio você pode chegar e dizer o
seguinte não essa idéia não quero pra
mim eu não quero pensar sobre isso então
você vai brincar com seu cachorro vai
brincar com seus filhos a fazer qualquer
coisa só que pensa que essa ideia ela
ficou naturalmente um dia inteiro letivo
pois bem imagine agora que essa idéia
fique triste forma persistente na sua
mente durante um mês
eu estou arrepiado
multiplique isso por um ano
multiplica por quatro anos
[Música]
se você somar mais dois anos que
geralmente o mestrado você vai entender
o quanto queremos chegar aonde estou
querendo chegar nós não temos o livre
arbítrio de tirar a idéia da cabeça ou a
gente fica com ela está conta daquilo
que a gente se prontificou a fazer
porque por n razões
a gente acredita na ação a gente
acredita na idéia de educação a gente
gosta de trocar etéreas e disseminar o
saber e é isso que faz com que a gente
fique literalmente na frente de uma tela
de computador deixando às vezes família
férias feriados e por aí vai
aí você poderia pensar não gostar não
tem nenhum momento que todo esse esforço
ele não encontra uma uma contra volta
claro que tem
é lógico que tem e na minha modesta
visão esse momento específico é a defesa
meus amigos como eu queria voltar na
minha defesa doutorado
choveu dez indicados a publicação coisa
foi maravilhoso como eu queria voltar
àquele dia e nesse caso eu pensei co
olha o tanto de 10 que eu tirei agora
sou doutor cara
legal eu acho que eu posso chegar 1% que
está projetando porque não lá meus caros
eu me sentia um super herói
e não é qualquer um não viu a adoro goku
a ele apanha apanha apanha e volta do
nada né incrível assim pra esse plano se
transformando em fim
então eu fico pensando nossa
se tem um dia que de fato eu senti que
fiz uma coisa grande foi do dia da minha
defesa
pois bem passado o tempo a gente vai
percebendo que não era muito da forma
que a gente imaginava
a gente sai do que eu chamo de bolha a
gustava quanto tempo demora pra mim
foram três semanas
nada mais do que isso enquanto eu falo
com com muita nobreza que eu saí pra
essa pole em três semanas tem jovens
doutores que estão nessa bolha ainda
hoje acreditam no mito de genialidade
que não existe
e nesse caso específico porque você sai
da bolha simples você vive num mundo
paralelo
então automaticamente quando você sai do
doutorado o que você pretende não agora
eu sou doutor eu vou continuar
escrevendo eu vou dar conta do trabalho
ou 18 anos aí seis anos mas subiu
cresceu ea super e também cada vez que
eu vou em casa meu pai meus pais não
ficando com mais idade
eu tenho que recuperar tudo isso eu
tenho que recuperar tudo isso não
importa as consequências afinal sou do
mtur
pois bem na medida em que você vai
tentando resgatar e trazer esse tipo de
perspectiva
esse jovem doutor ele vai entrando em
contato com algo que todo mundo faz
pós-graduação sabe falta de tempo não é
que a gente não quer é que falta o tempo
mesmo o tempo escapa das nossas mãos e
aí a gente começa a pensar se de fato
tudo aquilo que foi prometido ou tudo
aquilo que a gente imaginou que nós
mesmos seríamos era real e nesse caso
específico
eu acho muito interessante refletir um
pouco sobre essa questão de tempo e qual
a perspectiva quando se fala em tempo a
gente quer produzir
eu amo aquilo que eu pesquiso eu amo
aquilo que eu faço
só que em contrapartida quando eu sair
da bolha eu acredito que eu posso
tranquilamente conviver e me relacionar
com o tempo que passou é tempo para uma
vida inteira
se você somar graduação são dez anos mas
logo após as três semanas
os boletos foram chegando o clima tinha
passado
aí olhei um por cento complicou e foi um
lapso digamos assim eu passei a pensar o
seguinte não vai dar
eu não vou 0,00 0% do cliente foi pode
colocar a 0 uma vírgula da conta
aí você poderia olhar e dizer o seguinte
estava então quer dizer que você tá
olhando pra mim agora que você nunca vai
conseguir ser o cara que vocês piloto é
é isso que estou dizendo isso não te diz
motiva porque
então eu vou me sentir desmotivado
simplesmente o que eu vou entender que
eu nunca você 1% cara que o projeto em
si bon
e daí que o desafio existe uma
perspectiva que eu acho muito
interessante que é mais ou menos assim e
aí a gente pode pegar e articular toda
essa reflexão que seria mais ou menos
assim
academicamente falando e me perdoe eu
sou um jovem doutora não consigo sair da
academia case academicamente falando nós
fazemos milhares de coisas nós temos
relações sociais nós temos relações
afetivas nós temos várias circunstâncias
que agregam conhecimento
só que aquilo que você faz no dia a dia
a maior parte das coisas que você faz no
cabo e currículo
se todo mundo aqui conseguisse colocar
aquilo que faz todo dia no currículo
você seria um lado da capes estrelinha
de com o menino
só que como saiu numa faculdade
recentemente viver no cabo do lado bom e
aí nesse caso o que fica como
perspectiva
gustavo então você está me colocando
qual perspectiva você nunca vai
conseguir ser um por cento que você
projetou é que você tá ensino ano tão
que o conhecimento é limitado claro e
por que não seria
gente na vida limitada
esse problema transitório a gente tá
aqui pra aprender a nossa existência é
limitada
a gente cansa chora risada nossos amigos
são limitados os amigos que você convive
hoje com certeza não são os mesmos de 20
anos atrás e não vão ser os mesmos daqui
dez anos a família limitada sobre os 30
eu veria usam porque o conhecimento
seria limitado é entretanto porque cabo
entretanto sempre o fato de eu não
reconhecer o fato de o reconhecer as
minhas limitações não significa que eu
saiba até esse exato momento qual é o
meu limite e se eu não sei qual é o meu
limite eu corresponder cada vez mais
vendo mais estudando mais pesquisando
mais porque eu não sei qual é o meu
limite eu sei que não vou ser um por
cento que lhe foi melhor 0.001 por cento
do crime foi e nesse caso se tudo isso
possui limitações à vida as amizades
relacionamentos e o tempo que também é
limitado
eu agradeço a atenção de vocês com breve
atendendo
abra um livro para ler abrir o livro
sempre vai ser um ato de revolução muito
obrigado boa noite valeu
[Aplausos]